this is day one of the great challenge
so now first job today is to level the
field
now lee why is leveling the field so
important and how
do we do this for wet seated rice
you're dealing with a with a seedling
that is
two days old young and very fragile
and there's the two most important
criteria you've got to meet
early are water control and weed control
and in some ways they're one in the same
so by leveling you can ensure that each
each seedling has a consistent amount of
water
or a consistent lack of water depending
on what you're trying to achieve
at the time so we really think
leveling the field is the very first and
most important step probably to get the
good crop established
particularly if it's wet seeded rice as
we want to do in our agronomy challenge
this year
yes we're targeting a high yield and for
a high yield we need a good
establishment density we need a good
number of plants in the field so we need
a good survival of and growing of the
the seeds that we we will put out with
the drum seeder in two days time
and leveling is definitely the
foundation upon which
a good high yield is built and how does
that laser leveling thing work here
we have a big tractor we have a
attachment back there well what does it
actually do
right well there's two implement
electronic implements talking to each
other
the first implement is transmitting
transmitting a signal
over there at the other side of the
field it's sending a laser beam
and a completely level grade
the second device is picking up that
beam
and ensuring that the the implement the
rotavator
is traveling along the field at a
consistent height
so if it's traveling a consistent height
it's leaving the soil
at a consistent height so it's it's
achieving that final
final leveling we're looking to looking
at yeah lee i don't know what you think
but i think you've done a great job this
looks pretty level to me
i think it's satisfactory now my
leveling coach at the other end of the
field he assures me that this
leveling task is complete the leveling
is satisfactory
so we are ready to drum seed in two days
time to seed the field
fantastic see you back in two days thank
you